وسيله نقل تقليديه برز نشاطها لنقل
الفارين من الاشتباكات السودانيه من منطقه
جودا الشمالي الى داخل الحدود الجنوب
السودانيه ابرم معبر جودا الجنوبي وهي
وسيله بديله للسيارات التي توقفت حركتها
نسبه لشح الوقود
احيانا مواصلات ما عندنا هنا ما راضي يقود
ما عندنا والله بالليل والنهار
يعني
شعور غريب هكذا قالت
التي استقلت الكارو لاول مره
كوسيله نقل محليه قائله ان ظروف الحرب قد
تجبرك على استخدام اي وسيله لتصل بسلام
الى وجهتك
مشيره الى ان للحرب ظروفها وللضروره احكام
غريب جدا جدا
قطه الناس يمكن يضحكوا
الخروبات ده وكده
النساء والاطفال هم اكثر الفئات التي
تستخدم هذه الوسيله وهي وسيله بطيئه لكنها
سحله الحركه اذ تبلغ قيمه تذكرتها بين
الجودتين نحو الفي جناح سوداني
يعني حسب حسب الظرف مننا عندهم عنده
الفدان
الله سهله الامور
احنا حابين نساعدهم اكثر قصص وحكايه
ووسائل ستبقى صوره عالقه في افحان
الكثيرين خاصه الذين فره من المناطق
الساخنه الى مناطق امنه
مبيور شيرلو العربيه مابر جودا الجنوبي
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار
والقصه على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات